[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler bruno attal
président fondateur du collectif touche
pas à mon flic et david libeskind avocat
cofondateur du collectif robe noir et
gilet jaune bonsoir messieurs merci
d'être en direct avec nous alors le
procès de treize personnes pour cyber
harcèlement envoyé finalement au 21 juin
après l'examen de questions de procédure
pour les avocats des prévenus on serait
allé beaucoup trop vite dans cette
affaire qu'en pensez-vous david les
destine alors est-ce qu'on était trop
vite dans cette affaire je ne sais pas
mais ainsi qu'un l'afer a été renvoyé
pour des questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité déposées par juan
branco - donc avocats de la défense et
également parce qu'il y avait trop de
procédures concernant les gardes à vue
susceptibles d'être annulées alors de
deux mémoires
les prévenus si j'ose dire avait reconnu
à demi mot ce cyber harcèlement si j'ose
dire
donc je pense de toute façon quand ils
arrêtent que la question les questions
de critères de conditionner bon pas
donné grand chose et que de toute façon
va le procès va reprendre
voilà rapidement fin juin bruno est elle
à la sortie de l'audience me l'a affirmé
ceci il n'ya pas d'anonymat à partir du
moment où on commet un crime sur
internet on peut être vont chercher
peut-être retrouver on peut être jugé
devant un tribunal c'est ce qu'elle a
déclaré c'est ce que pense également de
nombreux spécialistes du numérique qui
nous voient finalement pas l'intérêt de
débattre du coup sûr la levée de
l'anonymat sur les réseaux sociaux
votre avis là-dessus on m'écoute et j'en
ai fait l'expérience
aujourd'hui donc j'étais au commissariat
de drancy puisque moi aussi j'ai fait
l'objet de menaces d'insultés puisque la
dernière menace que j'ai subi c'est je
passerai un prêt éric masson une vraie
menace de mort et donc il faut déposer
plainte
on a identifié sept individus qui s'est
présenté au commissariat qui a été
interpellé au commissariat de drancy est
en garde à vue aujourd'hui
donc oui effectivement il faut il faut
il faudrait lever l'anonymat bon après
c'est un voeu pieux puisque avec le
numérique on sait pas exactement
jusqu'où pourra aller mais effective est
effectivement pour chasser hausse est de
mise
cible ces lâches qui insultent et kim et
qui menace en ligne et qui se cache
derrière un pseudo comment se déroule
justement l'identification des auteurs
qui se cache derrière un pseudo écoutez
moi dans mon cas bon j'ai une équipe
d'informaticiens qui sont quand même
assez bon bon là on explique à ce jeune
homme qu'on allait chercher à 6 heures
du matin il a une crise de panique et
donc que nous a donnée comment son nom
son prénom et et et s'est présenté au
commissariat
mais voilà les investigations dans la
ferme il a encore une trotte 13
personnes de grands ont été recherchées
retrouver donc voilà donc il ya pas mal
de brou d'ailleurs je félicite mes
collègues d'avoir retrouvé ses 13 c tres
prévu nuit qu'ils soient j'espérais
aussi coupables voilà ceux sanctionnés à
la hauteur
hélas ce n'est pas souvent le cas david
les baies slim côté de la vie
législation sur le droit à l'anonymat
sur les réseaux sociaux
alors il a pas vraiment un droit à
l'anonymat en tant qu elle si on a
commis un délit ou un crime dans ce
cas-là l'hébergeur est obligé de donner
les noms de toutes façons des personnes
qui ont commis un crime ou un délit
après moi ce que je pense concernant
cette affaire c'est que le délit donc
bleus harcèlement en ligne et est puni
en quête d'une une peine de prison de
deux ans et des 30000 euros et j'ai
trouvé que l'ascension est complètement
disproportionnée parce que on sait très
bien que sur les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup de personnes sans pente à faire
des menaces mais c'est pas des menaces
vraiment réel des goûts des commentaires
déplaisants allant à l'encontre de la
personne en paix petit et le poste mais
dans ce cas là
je dire il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
aujourd'hui serait en garde à vue et
risque de la liste sur réseaux facebook
et vous verrez que les commentaires
qu'il ya beaucoup de menaces ya beaucoup
mais las des morts des injures racistes
de discrimination et j'ai trouvé en fin
de compte le législateur en permettant
que cette infraction soit sanctionnée
par un délit aller a été beaucoup trop
loin je pense qu'on pète d'amande aura
été suffisant benoît talent pourquoi pas
mais toute façon une sanction alors
qu'on parlait de deux ans
d'emprisonnement je ne pense pas qu'il
personnes a été emprisonné deux ans donc
enfin vous mélangez tout c'est à dire
effectivement entre ce qu'il ya dans le
code pénal
était ce qui est prononcée il ya
toujours comment un fossé entre les deux
donc effectivement sanctionner ceux qui
blessent sanctionner ceux qui harcèlent
alors que ce soit par une amende ou par
de la prison mais la prison il y en aura
jamais eu de façon il faut le
sanctionner pour qu'effectivement ces
personnes ne puissent ne recommence plus
et ensuite ça que je réglais ça passe
est un exemple pour les autres tout
simplement
si je peux apporter intervenir c'est pas
la police 1 qui les ciblent la peine en
ce qu'on parle de deux ans et ses deux
ans maximum donc après c'est aux juges
en fonction du casier judiciaire du
prévenu en fonction des cires et
circonstances de la commission du délit
qui décide s'il faut condamner à six
mois avec sursis ou ou à deux en 6e
si la personne qui le premier a un
casier judiciaire peu de frais et aux
crises donc ou s'il ya de la place en
prison et comme on n'a pas de place en
prison
de toute façon il ya que des peines
alternatives et qu'il faudrait à peu
près menacé dizaine de fois un individu
commet pour avoir de vraies sanctions
donc les cas comparer aussi d'amande en
général ce sont des gens qui sont
insolvables et qui sert très bien ce
qu'ils font donc de toutes façons encore
une fois dans tous les sujets avec la
justice une guérite censure dans ce pays
et donc le tout le monde et vous vous
comparez de propos racistes sur facebook
ou de harcèlement et vous avez
l'impression c'est quelque chose de
normal façon bon allez ça effectivement
bah oui mais bon c'est ce que vous êtes
en avant de dire je suis en maître donc
voilà la sanctionner ces individus qui
font énormément de mal parce que je peux
vous dire que quand à 3 heures du matin
bon il ya deux jours je reçois un appel
pour me menacer de mort je peux vous
dire c'est pas très agréable pour moi et
pour ma famille mais effectivement pour
vous salaire juste d'être une broutille
mais non monsieur imaginer
a quand même des milliers et des
milliers d'instituteurs de menaces qui
se retrouvent qui n'aura plus jamais la
même vie qui est obligé de se cacher de
se terrer et vont parler de huy une
petite amende
vous êtes franchement vous êtes hors sol
charme et vous êtes hors sol non non non
alors qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord alors
pour vous la situation différente parce
que vous avez reçu les appels
téléphoniques
donc pourquoi même distingué ce
qu'appelle t téléphonique que des
commentaires canadienne internautes pour
le soir de recevoir sur les réseaux
sociaux après la ferme là d'accord avec
vous c'est alors si beaucoup une menace
mais je veux dire n'y a pas que la
pierre mila bon là c'est une affaire
emblématique mais aller sur facebook
vous verrez que tu les commentaires
haineux violent entre d'internautes et
il a police dans ce cas là pourquoi
pourquoi ne les lui allizard atteint
pourquoi ne les met pas en garde à vue
vous savez cela qui fait la différence
qu'est ce qui fait la différence est ce
que c'est le contenu c'est le profil
dans la différence
non mais toute façon sur les réseaux
sociaux on peut pas se satisfaire de
l'impunité cette place à sow sur ce
sujet ou un autre quand des gens
enfreignent la loi il faut les
sanctionner tout simplement la
fectivement il ya une masse il ya une
masseuse insultes
il n'y a pas de raison toute personne
qui enfreint la loi doit traiter à être
sanctionné tout simplement et il ne doit
pas avoir deux poids deux mesures il ya
des gens qui souffrent des commandes de
ses commentaires des propos racistes
c'est quand même assez violent donc on
note des menaces de mort et je peux vous
dire que c'était vrai violence pour les
victimes dont que moi je suis policier
donc les policiers moi je veux ma seule
préoccupation ce sont les victimes
et donc les auteurs comment qui jour au
lendemain vous dise ah oui mais bon
j'étais un peu énervé non il ya pas il
ya pas de la librairie team aujourd'hui
dans cette société on ne s'occupe plus
des victimes on ne vous voyez depuis le
début de ce débat on ne parle que les
auteurs on ne parle jamais des victimes
est là moi ce qui m'importe monsieur
cissé des victimes alors justement on va
regarder ce sondage du figaro sur
internet daté d'hier à la question de
savoir s'il faut interdire l'anonymat
sur les réseaux sociaux le oui
l'emportent largement plus de 82% le nom
plus de 17% seulement une majorité de
oui donc est-ce que ce sondage il est
révélateur quand même d'un malaise david
libeskind mais après bon moi j'ai jamais
dit qu'il fallait qu'il fallait pas
interdire la limmat sur les socios sur
les réseaux sociaux
bien sûr vous voulez un gardien je veux
dire ça ça paraît évident d'aider des
gens commis des infractions donc pour
que l'hébergeur lève l'anonymat et pour
que ces personnes ne soient identifiés
moi ce que je parle en fait c'est le
deux poids deux mesures il ya peu de
commentaires à nu et ça je le répète et
vous l'avez reconnu monsieur sur sur les
réseaux sociaux est donc bien que fait
la police
puisque vous me dites en fait il faut
qu'il soit arrêté il sanctionné alors ce
cas la place il en garde à vue mais là
la police ne le fait pas alors pourquoi
ne le fait pas après ça peut se
comprendre la panne est hektik et aux
questions visant à ce genre vous faites
le droit pénal est l'opportunité des
poursuites appartient au procureur
public
s'il n'ya pas de place donc on ne peut
pas interpellé et placé en garde à vue
il va falloir un peu alors je crois que
c'est à vous en fait de retourner à
votre code pénal parce qu'il n'y a pas
besoin d'une plainte pour que l'action
publique soit déclenchée mais sa part
l'opportunité des poursuites
poser la question de savoir que fait la
police et les pouvoirs publics dans tout
cela le secrétaire d'état au numérique
cedreo estime de son côté que la
question de l'anonymat en ligne est un
très mauvais combat comment est ce qu'il
faut comprendre ces propos et puis
emmanuel macron il s'est exprimé
notamment sur ce débat lors d'une visite
dans le lot il tranche pas vraiment sur
la question il ya eu l'échec de la loi
via pour lutter contre la haine en ligne
la mort aussi de ses mails pâtit qui a
été pris pour cible sur les réseaux
sociaux
est ce qu'il ya un manque de volonté
politique justement pour lutter contre
la haine en ligne ou des données je
souhaiterais pertinents
c'est monsieur macro ne tranche pas quel
scoop le gouvernement du en même temps
comment voilà ne tranche jamais
et donc oui effectivement la haine en
ligne c'est un vrai problème qu'on doit
prendre à bras le corps et que
effectivement levé l'anonymat et je peux
vous dire que si on arrivait à lever
l'anonymat
je peux vous dire que vous savez à une
personne qui voir celle qui vous menace
en général n'est pas très courageuse
tout simplement donc le ciel des plus
anonymes et ben je peux vous dire que on
va peut-être avoir 90 % de moins de
haine en ligne de mon point de vue en
tout cas david les vestiaires non mais
la mer en fait le là là n'est pas le
débat puisque on peut lever l'anonymat
avec l'hébergeur il suffit que la police
contacter l'hébergeur à la loyale
l'anonymat est levé
donc c'est quand les personnes qui ont
des com - cap et ne scelle le ca elles
le savent
sauf quelques bons contres anglais 15
écoles interannuelle a vécu aussi dur
vous avez un travail qui étaient
moyennement justement parce que là je
vous parlais oui vous avez déjà engagé
quand un centre rapide policiers sur des
propos des excuses alors que lorsque
j'ai annoncé plus tôt les réseaux
sociaux effectivement les hébergeurs
mais c'est des réseaux sociaux
effectivement comment obliger une
personne à avoir une pièce d'identité
par exemple quand elle créé un compte et
conduit s'identifier assez facilement
avec une adresse avec un numéro de
téléphone
comment avec un nom prénom une photo oui
ça serait beaucoup plus simple et je
peux vous dire que 90 % des commandes et
messages et 2 voilà qu'en général ce que
vous savez le chien qui avoue n'avoir
pas et commencé ces haineux s'ils savent
qu'ils peuvent être identifiées assez
rapidement vous verrez que ça alors ça
sèche complètement d'accord avec nous
mais il suffit d'aller sur twitter par
exemple et tout le monde sait que sur
twitter il ya beaucoup de messages
haineux il ya même un syndicat de police
qui avait proposé en fait de supprimer
les avocats mini-camp à celle qu'a
police et à l'époque c'était quand même
un petit buzz médiatique
donc il ya quand même voilà des messages
haineux d'ailleurs l'épaule de seine 4
puis stap était poursuivi pour dire
qu'il ya quand même une justice à double
vitesse et pas en revenir sur twitter il
ya beaucoup de propos haineux qui ne
sont jamais poursuivis donc indépendants
les gens sont identifiés et les
personnes les six mois terminés le
souper de 10 personnes soient gerland se
sont identifiés par leur compte twitter
si elles identifient leurs malheurs
prénom il n'y a pas et il n'y a pas de
poursuite
merci en tout cas on va vous laisser
poursuivre peut-être
on a parti le débat merci à vous david
et des skins avocat cofondateur du
collectif robe noir et gilet jaune merci
à vous également bruno attal président
fondateur du collectif touche pas à mon
flic